en este vídeo veremos cómo modificar la
lámpara bebible para usarla como el
cuerpo de la araña y también veremos
cómo usar el interruptor para encender y
apagar la araña lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es quitar los tornillos usando
un destornillador de precisión como el
que usan los relojeros pueden usar uno
de cabeza plana ahora quitamos el lente
y el reflector y pueden ver que adentro
tenemos un led y un interruptor lo que
queremos es el interruptor no el led así
que tomamos nuestras pinzas y sacamos la
tableta en la que se encuentra no
tenemos que jalar con mucha fuerza pero
si queremos cortar los cables que la
tienen conectada tomamos la pinza
alicate y cortamos los cables ahora
tenemos que encontrar por dónde va la
energía para poder modificar este
interruptor hay dos rutas que queremos
conectar y queremos conectar la ruta de
aquí y esta otra ruta de acá estas dos
rutas nos permitirán completar el
circuito y usarlo para encender y apagar
nuestro robot
lo primero que vamos a hacer es quitar
el led vamos a desoldar lo vamos a
calentar los contactos de atrás y quitar
el led si no tienen una base como esta
siempre pueden pedirle a un amigo que
sostenga la tableta con unas pinzas
mientras ustedes le quitan la soldadura
y tienen que ser cuidadosos ya que es un
circuito muy pequeño y queremos mantener
la soldadura caliente alejada de
nuestras manos ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es insertar el primer conector del
cable y lo vamos a conectar del lado
positivo de la batería vamos a usar el
cable rojo porque este es el color que
casi siempre se usa para simbolizar el
lado positivo
vamos a usar soldadura sin plomo y vamos
a atravesar el cable en el agujero que
quedó cuando quitamos celes y vamos a
soltarlo en la ruta del circuito vamos a
asegurarnos que la soldadura toque al
cable y lo conecte la tableta vamos a
tener que calentarlo más ya que parece
que no está completamente conectado a la
tableta
bien que pudimos sacarlo muy fácilmente
ponemos de nuevo el cable lo mantenemos
en posición y nos aseguramos de poner
más soldadura en esta ruta es muy
importante tener una buena conexión con
este empalme y también es importante
evitar que se expanda la soldadura entre
dos contactos diferentes ahora volteamos
la tableta y ponemos más o la dura al
otro lado de la conexión para
asegurarnos de que es una conexión
sólida
ahora tomamos nuestras pinzas alicate
para cortar el exceso de material y
ahora vamos a tomar uno de nuestros
cables rojos y lo cortaremos con una
longitud de 2.5 centímetros y usaremos
nuestras pinzas alicates para cortarlo
no importa cuál de los dos cables
cortemos ahora tomamos nuestras pinzas y
pelamos una cuarta parte del cable y con
pelar me refiero a que le vamos a quitar
el aislante al cable y ahora ya lo
tenemos listo para conectar pero antes
de hacerlo quiero revisar de nuevo la
parte de atrás de la tableta para
asegurarme de que los cables rojos están
conectados correctamente queremos que
estos cables estén conectados a la ruta
de cobre o al área verde claro que está
en la parte superior del lado y el área
verde claro en el medio no lo conecte es
el cable rojo en el área verde claro que
está en la parte inferior derecha como
se ve en la imagen si lo haces así no va
a funcionar el interruptor